Disney CEO Bob Iger
has finally spoken out
on not only Disney's woke content that
they're putting out there for kids but
also the political campaign to pressure
Disney not to put out that woke content
and
what you're seeing reported in some
conservative media is that Disney is
backing away from the culture War you
know Disney has learned its lesson and
it's going to back away and and no
longer push this woke content on kids
that's not exactly what I'm hearing from
Bob Iger
there's a virtual question many cast
members had wished that Disney stayed
out of politics Will Disney stay out of
making political statements
you know I think there's a Mis
perception here about what politics is
and I think that some of the subjects
that have proven to be controversial as
it relates to Disney have been branded
political and I don't necessarily
believe they are I don't think when you
were telling stories and attempting to
be a good citizen of the world that
that's political
just not how I view it do I like the
company being embroiled in controversy
of course not it can be distracting and
it can have a negative impact on the
company and to the extent that I can
work to kind of quiet things down I'm
going to do that but I think it's it's
important to put in perspective what
some of these subjects are and not just
simply brand them political
so the way this is being reported I'll
give an example from Chris Ruffo who's
done excellent work fighting CRT
exposing all the crazy indoctrination of
kids he says exclusive I've obtained
video from Bob iger's first town hall
with employees in which he signals that
he will work to quiet things down
politically and move toward neutrality
in the culture War I agree with Chris
Ruffo on most things many many things
but I don't agree with his
analysis of what Bob Iger just said I
sort of think it's the opposite I think
what Bob Iger is saying is yeah I want
to quiet things down because I don't
want Disney's bottom line to get hurt
but I am not going to back away from the
culture War you heard what he said there
he said
uh listen certain things are being
described as political that I don't
think is or political at all such as
trying to be a good citizen of the world
first of all
anytime
you discuss citizenship You Are by
definition discussing something that is
political if citizenship is not
political nothing is political to be a
citizen is to be a member of a political
community so Bob Iger is either ignorant
of what politics is or he's being obtuse
there but to use that phrase citizen of
the world that's an extremely
politically loaded phrase to be a
citizen of the world
is is in conflict with being a citizen
of a Nation to be a citizen of the world
is to accept globalism which is one of
the most politically controversial
concepts of our age
and it's obviously Disney is leaning far
more in that direction and against the
nationalists so I I would that it were
so simple but I don't think that Disney
has learned anything I don't think that
Disney is
backing away from the culture where the
only thing that they've they have
learned there's one thing that they have
learned which is they've got to be a
little bit more subtle about it they
can't have their Executives out there on
camera saying we're going to push a not
so secret gay agenda no no they need a
secret agenda they need their their
radical agenda needs to be a little bit
subtler so it doesn't arouse the ire of
the ordinary American people to such a
point that you've got governors in
different states Ron DeSantis in
particular going in and punishing Disney
for pushing this kind of content okay
and that is why Disney feels that
they've got to make any changes
whatsoever it is because of Ron DeSantis
and Rhonda santis is taking a Victory
lap for that win
we didn't drag them in Tucker they went
in on their own and not only opposed the
bill they threatened to get it repealed
these are parents rights important
policies in our state that are very
popular and so they brought this on
themselves all we did was stand up for
what's right and yes they're a big
powerful company but you know what we
stand up for our folks and I don't care
what a burbank-based California company
says about our laws
now don't forget everyone is celebrating
what DeSantis did now but at the time it
was somewhat controversial on the right
you you had people on the right who are
more uh used to that kind of libertarian
language or the supposed neutrality of
the kind of bush era nice nice
neoconservative uh talking points uh the
people who say we never want to use the
government if we use the government that
makes us no different from the left the
kind of people who say I'm just going to
throw my hands in the air and go live my
own life
those are the people who said no
DeSantis is overreaching he's an
authoritarian he's a fascist he can't
tell Disney to stop transiting the kids
then you had then you had the
conservatives on the other hand can you
tell which side of this battle I'm on
then you had the conservatives on the
other hand who were saying this is
awesome good job keep it up to santis
wield the political institutions to
bring Disney into line that is what the
people want you to do
you not only have a right to do that as
governor of Florida you have an
obligation to do that good job keep it
up and though that was controversial at
the time you could see very clearly Ron
DeSantis leaning into the conservative
side more than the libertarian said and
he's going to keep doing it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]